Leonardo for one spent a fair amount of
time dissecting human cadavers because
he wanted to know how the various bones
related to one each other and how the
muscles related to the bones so he
wanted to have a realistic understanding
of the human anatomy because he was
depicting real-life people sitting
gesturing walking and he wanted to get
this is absolutely correct as possible
so in order to understand how the body
functions we need to know something
about the anatomy the body it's sort of
obvious the more we want to depict the
mind the more it helps to understand the
mind and one way to understand the mind
is to understanding the brain so it is
conceivable that as we get deeper and
deeper insights into the mind artists
will get ideas about how combinations of
similar effects for example emotional
states that will allow them to depict
those emotional states better but in
addition we're beginning to get in very
very primitive terms some insights into
the nature of creativity
huling Jackson the great neurologist in
the 19th century thought that the left
hemisphere is involved in language we
know this is true and the left
hemisphere is primarily involved in
logical processes calculation
mathematics rational thinking the right
hemisphere thought is more involved in
musicality which is true the sink song
in my language comes from the right
hemisphere the grammar and the
articulation comes from my left
hemisphere okay so he thought that the
right hemisphere is more involved in
musicality in you know synthesis putting
things together and in aspects of
creativity and he felt that the two
hemispheres inhibit one another so if
you have lesions of the left hemisphere
that removes the inhibitory constraint
on the right hemisphere and frees up
certain processes and he found that
certain kids that develop later in life
let's say and
teens and a facial language difficulty
it freed up in them a musicality which
they didn't have before people have
returned to that more recently in the
analysis of a dementia called
frontotemporal dementia frontotemporal
dementia is a dementia somewhat similar
to Alzheimer's disease actually begins
earlier that primarily affects the
temporal lobe of the brain and the
frontal lobe of the brain if it's only
expressed on the left side people with
frontal temple that meant dementia begin
to show creativity that they've never
shown before so if you were painted
before you might start if you develop
front the temporal dementia on the left
side to use colors that you've never
used before to try forms that you've
never used before if you never painted
before you might take up painting for
the first time so this is really quite
unusual there also group of people who
studied aspects of creativity I can give
you a problem that can be solved in one
of two ways
systematically working your way through
it
or putting it together take a guess and
a half phenomenon and they found that
when people do it in a sort of creative
way than a half phenomenon it's a
particular area in the right side of the
brain that lights up and they show this
not only with imaging but also with
electrophysiological recording so this
is really quite interesting the a number
of sort of indirect not the most
compelling evidence in the world the aha
phenomena is well documented but it's
only a component of creativity number of
suggestions there aspects of the right
hemisphere that might be involved in
creativity but look as we have been
saying all along with a very early stage
in understanding higher mental processes
so it's amazing we know anything about
creativity but this is certainly we're
heading into
era in which one can really get very
very good insights into it and the kinds
of situations that lead to increased
creativity you know is groupthink
productive does it lead to great greater
creativity or does it inhibit individual
creativity lots of these questions are
being explored both from a social
psychological and from a biological
point of view